Well, on Sunday mornings we've been going through a series looking at our statement
of faith as we're getting started as a church and we're walking through piece by piece looking
at that but most importantly what Scripture says about each one of these core doctrines
of our faith.
And so we're coming to the last couple.
We're looking at the church this week and next week and then the week after that,
God willing, we'll be looking at the second coming.
So that's, then we'll draw our time to an end looking at that together as we move into Advent.
But we're gonna, I'll just read the statement on the church and then Luke is gonna be reading
God's word to us and then we'll look at that passage together.
Here's our statement on the church.
We believe in the one holy universal church which is the community of all God's elect
for all time.
The church has been commissioned to be a light into the world and to make disciples
among all the nations.
We recognize the abiding significance of the sacraments of baptism and the Lord's supper.
We believe in the gifts of the Holy Spirit which will be used in service of the church
until the Lord returns.
So generally speaking, what are some of the things that come to mind when people
think of the church?
If you're just here somebody use the word church out and about today, what would
they be referring to?
They might say, you might ask them if they go to church anywhere and they say, I go to
such and such church and that could mean anything.
It could mean they have some connection there.
Historically, they were a member there at one point in time.
They know where they're going to be going on Easter Sunday and that could be the
extent of it.
And they might think of the church as an institution that you're part of, maybe
like you'd be, you have a gym membership somewhere or something like that.
Or they may think of it as an event.
You go to church.
It's what we're doing while we are there at that place.
Another thing that comes to mind is, let me say, I'll give you a statement.
Somebody said to me right as we were getting started at Cornerstone Ranch,
still meeting outside.
And they said to me, they said, well, I think this is somebody not here.
I think people will probably start coming to Trinity once you've got a church.
And what did they mean by that?
They meant a building, right?
So once you've got a building, then people will come to the church.
And so people are thinking of church as a building.
Now, facilities are important because they facilitate something wonderful,
but facilities are not the church itself.
The church is not a building.
The church has lots of different things that it does, activities that we are involved in.
And we're going to look next week at the practices of the church.
But at the end of the day, the church isn't the things that it does.
The church is a people.
So the church is the called out people of God.
It is the universal body of Christ in all places at all times.
But that universal body of Christ globally finds expression or it is embodied in local churches.
So scripture speaks about the church, but it also speaks about church as plural.
So there's one global church of Christ, but it's embodied in local churches like this one.
So put simply, we are the church.
We are the church.
And this is the church.
When you turn to Acts chapter two, that we begin to see take shape.
And this church is soon going to multiply and this church is going to carry on to this very day,
this very morning as we are gathered here as the people of God.
And this morning, we're going to focus on the identity of the church.
And next week, we're going to focus more on the practices of the church,
so who we are and then what we do.
So this morning, really, we like to walk through passages verse by verse here at this church.
However, we're going to focus on one word in Acts two, 42, and that's the word they.
And they devoted themselves to the Apostles, doctrine and teaching the breaking of bread and prayers.
We're just going to ask the question, who is the they here?
This is the church.
And so who is it?
And what we're going to do to look at that, I want us to if you've got a Bible with you
or you have a Bible app on your phone or you just want to look it up,
we're going to kind of look at Acts chapters one and two and see who is this they that is gathering
and doing these things that we just read about in Acts chapter two.
And then we're going to next week look at those specific things that they are doing.
Well, as you're looking at those first couple of chapters in Acts, you see that,
well, this they certainly includes the Apostles.
So right at the start of the book of Acts, you've got Jesus gathered with the 11 Apostles.
And later they're going to they're going to have another one joined their numbers.
You got the 12 Apostles.
So there's these early leaders of the church.
But then you read in Acts chapter one that there were you read about about 120 disciples
gathering together in one accord.
So you've got the Apostles, but you've also got the kind of wider church here.
The 120 disciples gathered together and they're praying together.
We saw last week, we saw as the Holy Spirit was poured out as we looked at the doctrine
of the Holy Spirit.
And this 120 people were then going out into the streets of Jerusalem and they are
proclaiming the mighty works of God to those who were there to celebrate the feast of of
Pentecost.
And so people at Pentecost just to jog or memory a little bit, you know,
they had traveled from all over.
You read about the various places that they had traveled from there at the start of chapter
two.
And when you look at the different places they were from, it's basically saying there are
people there from the north, from the south, from the east and from the west.
The House of Israel, so we had gathered from all four corners of the earth.
It's like a picture in that way of there.
They're all gathered together here.
It's not everybody but representatives from all these different directions.
And this includes Jews, but it even in chapter two and verse 11 tells us that includes some
Gentiles as well who had converted to Judaism.
And Peter stands up in the midst of them and preaches the gospel of Christ in the power
of the Spirit.
And over 3,000 people were converted that day.
They turned from their sin, put the trust in Jesus.
They made that public through baptism.
They're added to the church.
And that number we're told by verse 47 of our reading was growing daily.
So this is the church that we're reading about.
This is the they here.
However, the whole is greater than the sum of its parts here.
When it's saying they, it's not just talking about those people, although it's talking
about that too.
Because these people, all these people who were gathered together, some knew each other
well somewhere like brand new to the church, some were local, some were from far away.
But all of these people have been given a new identity to live out together as the
church, as the people of God.
And as you look at these opening chapters and acts in light of the overarching storyline
of the Bible and other places in scripture, a few things emerge here that tell us
about the identity of the church, who the church is.
And it tells us not only about them, but about us today as the church continues on.
So we're going to look at four things about the identity of the church from these chapters
and other places in scripture.
But first of all, we see that the church is a community, a community.
To state the obvious, the they here is plural.
You got a group of people, but then it goes on to share about the life that they have
in common with each other.
So you know, if this weekend you went to a movie theater somewhere, you might have
gone in, seen a great movie, it might have been packed with all kinds of people, and
you're at this event in this building, but then you then left, and it wasn't a community.
It was a lot of different people from different places gathered together, but it wasn't
a community.
The church is different.
The church is a community that is highly participatory.
Some people might treat the church in that way.
It's like it's just an event that you go to and you leave, but that's not what it is.
It is a community where we participate in this common life we've been given in Christ.
And you know, we live in a culture that is where people are starving for real, deep,
authentic community.
And actually the U.S. surgeon general had described loneliness as an epidemic in the U.S.
And you can go and read what he wrote.
All these different illnesses that he would tie to our loneliness.
There are all kinds of health risks literally associated with that.
And so it's not a stretch to say we need community.
We need it.
We need it here.
That's true all over the world.
And we need community because we were created for community.
We were created for it.
You know, God exists in community.
So there is one God, but He exists eternally in three persons, Father, Son, and Holy Spirit.
So when we look at whose Scripture reveals God to be, yes there's this one God, perfect
unity, but you have these three persons, Father, Son, and Spirit in this eternal loving
relationship with one another.
When God creates us in His image, He also creates us for community.
He makes us that we might know fellowship with Him.
He brings us into this fellowship with Him, Father, Son, and Spirit.
But He also makes us that we might know fellowship with one another.
So we need community.
So as the creation account unfolds, and by the way, as we've walked through firm
foundations, you may have noticed every single message we've looked back into Genesis
one to three because we saw all of this in seed form there.
So you go back to that early account of creation.
It says repeatedly that creation is good.
God looks at it, it's good, it's good, it's good.
But then in chapter two and verse 18, God looks at part of His creation and He says
not good.
It wasn't that something was wrong, but it was incomplete.
It wasn't finished yet.
He looks at the man He creates and He says it is not good for man to be alone.
So then He then creates marriage and family.
You see that continuing on, by the way, within the community of calling out the people of God
and of Israel.
So He created us for community.
And community was disrupted by the fall.
So when we sinned against God, Adam and Eve sinned against God, their relationship with
God was disrupted.
You know, God is walking in the cool of the garden.
Or they hear the sound of the Lord walking in the cool of the garden.
And instead of walking with Him, now they're hiding from Him.
Community with God disrupted.
And then when they're brought out, God's speaking to them, they're blaming one another.
So their relationship with each other is disrupted because of sin as well.
So disunity and division start to play out because of sin.
But nevertheless, it remains true that we are, we long for community because we're created
for it.
You see this expressed in the family or in nations.
When you get to the New Testament and Pentecost in particular, you see that all this is leading
to God's called out community, the church.
See, God invites us to be part of this new community.
So as Peter preaches at Pentecost, he's proclaiming the way that we can be reconciled
to God and no fellowship with Him once again through Jesus.
He talks about how according to the Father's plan, Jesus came into the world and He died
at the hands of sinful man.
He rose again and ascended to His heavenly throne.
He makes it clear that if you turn from your sin to Christ, you can know life with Him.
You'll be forgiven, reconciled to God.
And that inward reality.
We'll look at this more next week.
But that inward reality is then expressed with this outward sign of baptism.
Read about that next to 38.
Our baptism is an outward expression of the new identity that we have been given in Christ.
So we're identifying with His name.
And this is an identity that we share in common as the people of God because through
Christ we've been united not only to God, but also to one another.
We share this common identity as the people of God.
So God unites us to one another if we are in Christ.
So a few things about that.
One is that community isn't something that we create.
I hope it's something that we not only long for, but like work at together.
You know, we do have to work at it in some ways to experience that communal life together.
But community isn't something we achieve.
It's something that God has already given us.
We're seeking to live out who we already are in Christ.
So it's given to us.
And this community that's been given to us is a diverse community.
It's truly diverse.
You got people gathered in Jerusalem from all over the world who are brought into
the family of God.
This gospel is to be proclaimed to everyone, everywhere, to all nations,
all sorts of people.
And even in this room we got different people from different backgrounds and
different personalities and all the rest in here.
So God gathers a diverse community.
When you look at it globally, you see that Christ came to bring people from every
tribe, tongue and nation into his family.
I went to a talk by a guy called Christopher Watkin this week.
I got to make sure I don't say Christopher Walken.
That's a completely different guy for those of you who know who that
actor is, wasn't him.
This is a guy who's a university professor in Melbourne, Australia.
And he was in Birmingham this past week giving some talks.
And he's written some different theology books and that kind of thing.
And he has a really good perspective on Western culture.
But he showed a picture.
I wish I could show you the picture.
We don't have any screens yet of this advertising campaign.
It was fascinating.
And it was an advertising campaign for
a company called the General Pamps Company.
And they had on there, you had all these models wearing the different
clothing that are there.
And it said across it, it said we are Gen P, led by none.
That's the advertising campaign.
We are Gen P, led by none.
And he pointed out some of the irony of that campaign.
If you can kind of see that in your mind's eye.
First of all, to say like we're led by none.
So if you want to be part of our group who says that you're not led by
anybody, then follow us in what we're doing.
I hope you can already see the irony in that.
We're led by none, so come be with us, follow our fleet.
But another thing that was ironic that he pointed out was how it's like
subtly dealing with identity as well.
So we are Gen P, you can see it by the way we dress and
the brand of clothing we are wearing.
So if you buy the clothes that we do and wear them,
then you can be part of us.
We are this new generation, Gen P.
Gen P, they pointed out something very, very interesting.
That if you want to be part of this community, this cool community,
well then you really have to live in the part of the world that they are living in.
It's very specific.
And it was a very specific generation of people as well that they were kind of
appealing to.
And also you've got to be able to afford that brand of clothing as well.
So if you were one of these people say in Bangladesh who was sewing that
clothing, you've got no chance if you're not from the same like socioeconomic
strata that these folks are.
So it was actually a very exclusive community as inclusive as they
thought they were communicating.
Jesus by contrast gathers a truly diverse community made up of people
from every tribe, tongue, and nation, every socioeconomic background.
You can belong, but you have to come by way of the cross.
So it was exclusive in the sense that it is Christ community.
He is the head of his church, but it's a truly diverse community.
So the community that we long for is found in Jesus and through him.
And that's experienced as we live out our identity as the church.
And then our fragmented culture that's starved for true community.
The church really has an amazing opportunity to show where true community
can be found.
Okay.
A bit less time on the next ones we'll look at.
The next picture we see is that the church is a family.
The church is a family.
There was a meme I saw not too long ago online that cracked me up.
And it was Michael Scott when he first started his job at the office.
And he was shaking the hands of the boss that was taller than him.
I don't know if you've seen this online and at the top it's got a little
speech bubble by the box.
And it says like, you know, at our, you know, something like here, we're family here.
We're all family.
And then by Michael Scott it says, me who applied to 30 other families this week.
The thing is when scripture talks about the church as family, it's not just like,
you know, I don't know, something at work trying to do some team building or
some like bring some cohesion, like some loyalty to the company or anything like that.
It's, it's not that we are like family if we're part of the church.
It's that we are family.
It's not just an illustration.
We are a family.
This is a spiritual reality.
It's not just something that's aspirational.
If you're in Christ, you're part of the family of God.
Now, this is more implicit than explicit in Acts chapter one and two, but it is there.
If you look back at Acts chapter one versus 13 and 14.
It tells us that there are 120 people gathered there, but
they give a few names of the people that are gathered there.
And you think, well, why are they telling us these specific people?
It tells us the names of apostles, but then it also talks about those who were
members of Jesus earthly family as well.
And so you think, well, why is it telling us about these people,
these family members of Jesus and the apostles names?
Well, one of the things is that it could be to show us the significance
of the language that follows immediately after in verses 15 and 16.
When Peter addresses that group of 120 people, we've got family members there,
or people who have got positions of leadership or whatever.
He addresses all of them as brothers and sisters in Christ.
So there's some of them sat right next to their earthly families and
all different sorts of people, but all of them are brothers and sisters.
They're part of the family of God.
See, Jesus calls us family.
You hear that in his earthly ministry in Mark chapter 12, for example.
Jesus' mother and brothers were standing outside one time.
These are some of these people who were gathered there in the 120 in Acts.
And they're asking to speak to him, but then Jesus replies to the man who
told him, and Jesus says this.
He says, who is my mother?
And who are my brothers?
And stretching out his hand towards his disciples, he said, here are my
mother and my brothers, for whoever does the will of my father in heaven is
my brother and sister and mother.
How does Jesus define family here?
His relatives are looking for him and he points to his disciples and says,
this is my family.
He expands this to include all of his followers.
They're part of his family.
Now, our earthly relatives are important, but they're not ultimate.
However, the family of God goes on forever.
Now, don't mishear me.
We are called certainly to love and provide for our earthly families.
You know, some of Jesus last words on the cross were to one of his disciples,
you know, making arrangements for his mother to be looked after.
So what Jesus says isn't to diminish our immediate earthly families, but
rather to elevate the church and say, this is truly family and it's an
eternal family.
And we ought to therefore live as family.
That kind of language goes on throughout the New Testament describing the church.
You've got lots of different images used to describe the church in the New
Testament that we're not going to cover this morning.
But the most frequent, the most common is family.
Then places like Ephesians 2.18, it speaks about how we were once
strangers, but now we're called members of the household of God.
The most common way you find early Christians describing one another is
things like brother or sister familial language over 250 times in the New
Testament.
They described one another as family.
And the church family is a precious gift.
That precious gift is only realized experience as we as we live in light of
who we are.
So Mark chapter 10, verses 29 and 30, really hear this.
Jesus said, truly, truly, I say to you, there is no one who has left house or
brothers or sisters or mother or father or children or lands for my sake and
for the gospel who will not receive a hundred fold now in this time houses
brothers and sisters and mothers and children and lands with persecutions
and in the age to come eternal life.
So what's he saying here?
He's saying that sometimes following him means leaving behind earthly homes or
families, being rejected by family because of following Christ.
But that doesn't mean you're without a home or without a family.
He ends by talking about our eternal home, but he says you don't have
to wait for that to experience home and family.
When you follow him, you are part of a family and you're welcomed into
the houses of this family and on the lands of this family.
So this is very tangible and specific.
You are going to experience true family and all that comes with it.
But in this life and in the life to come.
So let me put this negatively and I'll put it positively.
How tragic would it be for somebody who's, you know, say become a Christian
and been rejected by their family or whatever and to step into the church
and find relationships to be shallow, superficial, you know, just event
attending together, that kind of thing when the church is truly a family.
So you see what Jesus is talking about there in Mark 10 is that when we
truly welcome each other into one another's lives and homes and take
care of one another as family, we are demonstrating that we are truly a family.
So this is something we can grow in together as the people of God living
out our identity as as family.
God's spirit helps us to to live, live this out.
You know, this this happens on Sundays and in informal ways and that kind
of thing, but just just so you know as well, maybe we'll look at this more next week.
That's why we have home groups in the church, too, is is just aiming to have
a place where facilitating that family life.
Thirdly, the church is a temple.
The church is a temple.
We looked at this last week, but we saw the outpouring of God's spirit
at Pentecost and we looked at the strange kind of ways it takes place.
You've got the sound of wind and the appearance of fire and and how these
are kind of callbacks to the temple in the Old Testament where God's presence
dwelt among his people.
It's making it clear through the way in which this happens that God's
spirit is not not now dwelling in a place, but in his people.
So in our reading in Acts 2, we saw that they were going to the temple
together, these early Christians, but they were also meeting in houses.
And God's presence was there as they met together in the temple.
Yes, but even when they poured out of there into houses, God's presence is still
with them because they are the temple.
Right. So this is pictured in the events of Pentecost, but it's made clear
through many specific passages throughout the New Testament as well.
But one of those places is 1 Corinthians chapter three, verses 16 and 17.
And before I read it, let me say that one of the limitations
of the English language is the lack of a plural you,
which kind of say you and that could mean just you specifically or all of you.
But that's the case unless you live in the south, because we've got an answer
for that, don't we? And that's y'all. All right.
And I was I was just looking at a book and it pointed out,
you know, that in 1 Corinthians three that actually all of the all of the
use that are here in verses 16 and 17 are plural use.
And they said, if you stick y'all in there, that's what it's about.
So I'm going to I'm going to read it in that way.
So I don't know if you have 1 Corinthians three in front of you,
but the use there are plural.
So it is absolutely faithful to the text to read it in this way.
It says, do y'all not know that y'all are God's temple
and that God's temp God's spirit dwells in y'all.
Anyone who destroys God's temple, God will destroy him for God's temple
is holy and y'all are that temple.
So we're the temple, y'all.
I mean, but sometimes sometimes that verse is read
in a very individual way.
See, sometimes we can read passages in the New Testament specifically.
We think, oh, this is about me. This is me and Jesus was actually.
It's a collective thing.
It's talking about the church, talking about our life together.
And this is one of those.
So we collectively are the temple. God's spirit dwells among us.
As we're, yes, he dwells in us individually.
So that's true also. But here, as we gather together as the Lord's people,
God's presence is with us.
You know, 1 Peter chapter two and verse five, Peter talks about believers
being like living stones built up as a spiritual house.
Paul deals with this in Ephesians as well.
It talks about how God has brought us together in Christ,
that we might be a dwelling place for God's spirit.
So what are the implications of that?
One is that God himself is at work in his church.
Let's not forget that the amazing things that we see taking place
that we'll look at specifically next week are evidence of God's presence
and God's power amongst his people.
It isn't just like, here's a list of things they did.
Now you go and do likewise is saying, look what God is doing amongst these people.
And that same God is present at work among us.
And he produces those things in our life.
So the Holy Spirit is shaping our lives together as the people of God
that we might know Christ and make him known in the world.
So when we gather, let's pray that God would make us more acutely aware of that reality,
that God is present and at work among us.
But also another implication is that God is present with us wherever we go.
And that's relevant for us right now, isn't it?
You know, over the years I've had the joy of worshiping with other believers
in beautiful ornates, church buildings like in England,
but also like a clearing in a cornfield in Burkina Faso
or a crammed apartment complex in Belarus, former Soviet Union.
But in all of those places, all of those places were a sanctuary.
God's holy temple was there.
God's presence was dwelling among us
because his presence is with us wherever we go.
So wherever we gather, including wherever we gather in the coming year,
the Lord will lead us there and he will be with us wherever we are in that place.
We'll be a temple because we are that temple.
Lastly, the church is a kingdom outpost, a kingdom outpost.
If you've ever been to a U.S. Embassy in another country,
you'll know that it's like often like walking into like walking into
an American building on American soil,
like the furniture will be shipped in from the U.S.
And the ways of operating will be from the U.S.
You're in a foreign country, but in that space,
it's a kind of an outpost of another country
and that's reflected in lots of different ways.
The same is true about the church.
See, the book of Acts is framed by the kingdom of God.
When you look at the early, early verses, Acts one, verse three,
Jesus is teaching his apostles about the kingdom of God.
Then when you get to the very end of the book of Acts, what do you have?
You've got the Apostle Paul in the heart of the Roman Empire.
And what is he doing?
He is teaching people about the kingdom of God,
showing them that Christ is king and he's telling them what the kingdom of God is truly about.
And in our immediate context in Acts one and two,
Peter has just proclaimed that Jesus is the promised king.
He is now seated on his throne in heaven.
That the presence and powerful work of the spirit on earth
is showing that Jesus is truly reigning in heaven.
So as the church is gathering together and being shaped by the spirit,
what is that demonstrating?
It's demonstrating that Jesus truly is king.
We are part of his kingdom.
It's showing that Christ reigns over all things.
His reign is being revealed in the world when his church confesses him,
his lordship and follows him as king.
The church is an outpost of the kingdom.
This kingdom life is beautifully portrayed for us next to here.
You know, you've got the people of God gathering there.
They're worshiping the king.
They're following the ways of the king.
You know, Jesus, Jesus is king, but he loved others and he he reigns by
serving others as well.
And so you see Jesus lovingly laying down his life for his people.
So as his people are now following the reign of the king, following his ways,
while they're lovingly laying down their lives for one another, serving one another
in very practical ways.
And they're bearing witness to the king.
And as they're doing that, the Lord is adding to their number day by day.
So sure, they're in the Roman Empire, but they are part of another kingdom.
Jesus is the king.
And the same is true for us where we're sat this morning.
Christ is our king and may his wonderful reign be seen in our lives as we follow him
together. What a privilege it is to be part of the church,
to be part of God's community, to be part of his family,
to know that he dwells with us
and to be citizens of his glorious kingdom.
So.
Just two questions for us to ponder as we come to pray.
Are you part of this church?
Have you turned from your sin and put your trust in Jesus?
Have you been reconciled to God and brought into this community that he's
building called the church?
I hope so.
I hope you know Christ as your savior and your king.
The second question is this.
Are you participating in the life of his church?
He's given us this identity.
I hope we realize that we're told this that we might lean into that identity,
that we might live as the people that he has.
Called us to be.
I wonder if there are any practical steps.
I don't know what that is for you, but are there any practical steps that you
could take even this week to live out this collective identity
that we've been given in Christ?
Maybe ponder that as we as we pray together, let's pray that the Lord
would deepen our life together as the people of God.
Let me pray and then you can continue on in prayer as our music group comes forward.